best-selling author Harlan Coben is so
more than 70 million books worldwide
he's famous for its domestic thrillers
Colvin's last ten consecutive novels all
debuted at number one on the New York
Times bestseller list thank you very
much his 30th and newest novel is called
don't let go it's the story of a New
Jersey detective who's haunted by the
past he's looking for answers about the
mysterious death of his twin brother and
the disappearance of the love of his
life happened about the same time Harlan
Coben joins us back at the table good to
see you again
know that your best-selling artha when
your name is so much bigger than the
title of book publishing Charlie that's
great he's very dead Charlie Rose but I
just want to start with the first line
of this book okay you'll like this to
try this is this noir listen to two
years daisy wore a clingy black dress
with a neckline so deep it could tutor
philosophy with a plunging neckline
I just thought have fun with the first
line because we're about to get dark so
I just have a little turn very quickly
yes it does I love the idea of this book
came actually from your childhood yeah I
grew up in New Jersey in a suburb of New
Jersey and there was a rumor when I was
a kid that behind Rikard Hill elementary
school behind his barbed wire fences
there was a secret military base that
had missiles Nike missiles with nuclear
capabilities and of course as a kid you
think it's nonsense and when I grew up I
found that it was true yeah we actually
had these bases there's 14 of them
around New Jersey that are protecting
Philadelphia and New York from the 50s
to about 73 74 so did you go back yeah
you can go back now actually it's an art
park but the rusted remains are still
there it's kind of weird that it's all
broken down but you could still see old
radar towers and things like that they
built over where they had the missiles
it's now called Nike Drive and for
housing develop your knowledge what does
that do for you to discover that it's
you know especially I was a kid it stirs
your imagination I mean all that is
wandering in the woods as a kid I think
it's a lot of what being a writer is
about and so I imagine these kids going
in the woods kind of trying to explore
it kids used to go out there drinking
when I was in high school near the Bay
people tell stories about being chased
away all that stuff it doesn't stir your
imagination you're not a writer there's
a makeup corner but makeout corner back
there so the lead guy is Napoleon
Detective Napoleon dumo they they call
naps map but but he is very different
you said darker than most men that
you're right about yeah I wanted
somebody you know he lost his twin
brother and this book is the first time
I've done this words first person
present-tense was telling the story to
his dead brother talking to his dad yeah
and he's trying to find out what really
happened to him out in the woods when
they were in high school he's trying to
find the truth so I'm trying to both
break your heart and stir it a little
bit oh you do that this is this is your
30th novel yeah you're in so incredibly
prolific how is that what's your
technique it's just you know it's my job
I I you know a plumber can't say Oh
today I can't do pipes and too important
I treat it like a job I get down right I
try to write and if I don't write I hate
myself there's a lot of self-loathing
involved and in a good creative process
so if I don't write I beat myself up
until I get back to work and you and Dan
Brown are friends what was interesting
so together and this is what he says
about you Harlan Coben is a modern
master of the hook and twist luring you
in on the first page only to shock you
on the last and that's certainly true
with this but I'm wondering when two
writers get together are you very
secretive about your working what you're
working on like what are you doing
nothing what are you doing or do you are
you you share dan and I talk about
everything but writing I mean writers
never you know I'm friends with a lot of
writers we never really talked about our
process or what we're working on
politics religion everything else but
normally we don't talk about what we're
working on I think it's also it's bad
karma to talk about your book I think
it's I'm dying to tell you the story the
only way I'm gonna get that satisfaction
is to actually write it and people talk
about their book it's usually bets and
blank page doesn't scare you
it's terrifies me the blank page it
terrifies me but that's what you have to
kind of face each day and you have to
fight it each day but yeah the idea is
that you have to you can't just find an
excuse not to not to face you can't say
oh I don't like the blank page today I'm
gonna watch TV or I'm gonna go to the
mall and you got a TV show on Netflix
that they call dangerously bin jabal
yeah about all of your books it's called
the five it's a story of five kids that
are also
the woods and one disappears in 20 years
later these five result he comes back
and it's been one of those shows that's
sort of catching on Netflix we love it
we filmed it in Britain it's been a lot
of fun and if you look closely you'll
see Harlan Coben on the screen episode 9
Harlan Coben always great to have you
guys it's great to see you thank you so
much thank you don't let go it's
available now